what is your favorite thing about
Candace Owens and and what is one thing
you disagree with her on uh well my
favorite thing about Katniss is that she
will say things that nobody else will
say my least favorite thing about
Candace is that you will say things that
nobody else will say
um yeah
I mean listen she she says things that
are audacious and I think need to be
said sometimes sometimes I think that
she is morally wrong right I think the
way she responded to Kanye I've said
this clearly was dead wrong and morally
wrong what was her response her original
response was that she proffered
confusion of what yay was actually uh
talking about uh and then she you know
was defending her friend I wish that the
way that she had responded was by saying
he's my friend and also he said
something bad and anti-Semitic I wish
that you'd said that right so right away
right away yeah I think you can also
this is the interesting human thing you
can be friends with people that you
disagree with and you can be friends
with people that's actually say hateful
stuff and and one of the ways to help
alleviate hate is being friends with
people that's that that say hateful
things yeah and I'm calling them out on
a personal level when when they do say
wrong or hateful things yeah from a
place of love and respect and privately
privately is also a big thing right I
mean like like the public demand for for
you know denunciation from friends to
friends uh is is difficult and I I
certainly have compassion for for
Candace given the fact that she's so
close with you
yeah it breaks my heart sometimes the
public the public fights between friends
and broken friendships I've seen quite a
few friendships publicly break over
covid
covert make peop made people behave
their worst in many cases which
um
yeah breaks my heart a little bit
because like the the human connection
is uh a prerequisite for Effective
debate and discussion and and battles
over ideas